So it's not obvious on first consideration
why discussed would be a moral
emotion.
So you know,
most of the work that's done,
it's outside of the disgust realm I
would say is predicated on the assumption
that the reason that
conservatives in particular,
but perhaps people who
are more authoritarian and
general draw boundaries around
their territories because
they're afraid of the other.
But that isn't really,
that isn't really how it plays
out as far as I can tell.
Because conservatives for example,
are less neurotic than treat in the
big five traits sense than liberals.
Although it's,
it's a minor difference.
But the disgust issue seems
to be particularly relevant.
So,
so can you tell us a little
bit about why disgust per se?
Well,
first conservatives are
a little less neurotic,
but they also add,
if you do very low level
perceptual experiment,
just like a puff of
white noise in the ear,
people who react more strongly to that
to any sort of very low level threat are
more likely to vote
Republican in this country.
So they're there.
You know,
there are all these interesting
personality differences
that lead to different
politics.
But as for why discussed?
Um,
so I'm,
I'm uh,
Durkheimian I would say I love the,
uh,
the sociologists,
Emile Durkheim,
and I'm also,
I'm a social psychologist,
so I'm always thinking not about people
as individual utility maximizers but
people as members of social groups,
people who are totally
focused on belonging in their
social groups and people
who have some pro social motives
about keeping the group together,
about doing things that
are good for the group.
So as I tried to argue in my book,
the righteous mind,
yes,
we're selfish.
There's no doubt that we often will do
things to advance our own self interest
at the expense of others.
But we're also really groupish,
which means we'll do all sorts of things
to advance Eric Group at the expense of
others.
Basically,
we're tribal,
we evolved as a tribal
species and we're doing,
we have all this software,
I would know all this,
all these predispositions,
these mental predispositions for life in,
in tribes that are battling other tribes.
And that's why it comes out so easily.
If you look at the way boys organized
themselves when they get up fraternity,
um,
the hazing rituals,
when you look at the weight,
it's especially clear in boys,
uh,
the way street gangs organized themselves.
Girls,
tribalism is a little different.
Um,
but I would say this is,
and that's why,
again,
I love the [inaudible] approach
of archetypes or something.
There's just this weird
stuff that is pan human.
Even if it comes out slightly
differently around the world,
there really is a human nature and it
comes complete with a whole bunch of like,
predesigned ideas.